[Musik]
das podcast ist platin bei rm unique
guten abend also ich spreche über ein
neues halo andere politisches weltbild
fragezeichen ja die die frage ist gibt
es das oder sollte es das geben sie
sehen mich da sitzen zwischen solchen
rekonstruktionen von vor früh urmenschen
ja die wir kürzlich eine ausstellung
gezeigt haben
die frage ist die erste frage ist
natürlich wie kommen überhaupt darauf
also die will ich heute abend
beantworten dann geht es natürlich um
die frage wo ist die menschheit
entstanden das ist ein altes thema
und dann natürlich wie ist sie
entstanden ja und überall da spielen
weltbilder eine große rolle werde ich
ihn gleich zeigen deswegen das wort
weltbild im titel also zunächst mal die
frage was haben wir überhaupt als als
grundlage für die rekonstruktion das
sind im wesentlichen knochen und zähne
die härtesten bestandteile im körper
also haare blutgefäße nerven und
sozialisieren nicht also sprache fossil
ist auch nicht sozialverhalten auch
nicht das heißt wir haben eigentlich nur
fragmente dieser ehemaligen lebewesen
dass der eine punkt und der andere punkt
ist dass diese fragmente sich nicht
selbst interpretieren ja also wer
schonmal fossilien gefunden hat oder
archäologischer funde
ich meine der weiß diese fossilien sind
einfach stumm die sagen gar nichts hängt
auch kein zettel dran ist war ein
vormenschen urmensch und so das heißt
wir interpretieren ja und wenn wir
interpretieren können wir das ja
natürlich nur in unserem jeweiligen
weltbild tun ja ich sage mal ein
beispiel hier diese österreichische
briefmarke da ist ein lindwurm ein
drache abgebildet ja dieser steht in
klagenfurt vor dem stadthaus ja und die
ursache für diese rekonstruktion war
dieser und ja im sechzehnten jahrhundert
rekonstruiert ein solcher schädel ist in
klagenfurt schon im zwölften jahrhundert
gefunden worden
im 16 jahrhundert als drache
rekonstruiert ja und und dieser dieser
schädel hier den gibt es heute noch in
klagenfurt und der wurde als trucker
registriert weil der schädel für nichts
anderes gepasst hat als für einen
drachen
und zwar drachen waren teil des
mittelalterlichen weltbildes ja gab
sogar bücher über drachen wie viele
drachen es gab wie die sich vermehrt
haben und so weiter das heißt es war
völlig logisch in diesen
mittelalterlichen weltbild diesen
schädel als drache zu rekonstruieren ja
heute rekonstruieren wir diesen schädel
als was völlig anderes nämlich als ein
wollnashorn ja ein eis zeitliches wir
sind der eiszeit vielfach in
mitteleuropa gelegt hat so und jetzt
sagt man na ja das was die damals
gemacht haben
das war ja alles falsch dieser drachen
nein das war natürlich nicht falsch sind
es war sehr wahrscheinlich im damaligen
weltbild und unsere rekonstruktion heute
ist auch nicht etwa wichtig sondern sie
ist eben nur wahrscheinlicher in unserem
heutigen weltbilder ich bin ich will
damit nur sagen es gibt in dieser
wissenschaft der paläoanthropologie die
eine historische wissenschaft ist aber
eben ohne historische inschriften
urkunden überlieferung von menschen gibt
es eben kein richtig und kein falsch
ja also das was ich ihnen sage kann
nicht richtig sein das kann auch nicht
falsch sein
es kann eben nur wahrscheinlich oder
unwahrscheinlich seien in sozusagen
bezogen auf eine hypothese evolution ist
natürlich sozusagen das was heute in
unserem wissenschaftlichen weltbild eine
große rolle spielt wenn man eine
zeitlang zurückgehen auch mal in 16
jahrhundert also die vorstellung des
ursprung des menschen hier im paradies
hier im siebzehnten sieht das so ein
bisschen rustikaler aus im achtzehnten
jahrhundert werden dann erste fossilien
als überreste des menschen identifiziert
das war ein großer salamander ja und
dann schließlich natürlich wissen sie
alle charles darwin hat natürlich mit
der evolutionstheorie einen großen
schritt sozusagen ihnen die heutige
wissenschaftliche in das heutige
wissenschaftliche welt bild gemacht bzw
wir sind in diesem weltbild mit mit
seiner arbeit über die der den ursprung
der arten so und arten biologische arten
wurden beschrieben sozusagen für alle
tiere und pflanzen von carlina das
wissen sie wahrscheinlich und carl von
linné hat auch den menschen dort
eingebunden also in der ersten ausgabe
von diesem werk systeme natur ist von
1735 hat carl von linné hier steht home
also der mensch ja da hat er hier vier
verschiedene menschen drin ja also
europäisches amerikaners asiatisches und
africanus je nach also mit den farben
weiß rot gelb und schwarz ja das ist
eine reine art beschreibung wie man sie
bei tieren auch machen würde damit
sozusagen mit also mit einer
beschreibung des äußeren so das war 1734
dann 1758 in der in der nächsten auflage
der der auflage von 1758 er war noch ein
paar dazwischen ja passiert plötzlich
etwas ja was sagen ganz grundlegend wird
eigentlich für die auch für die
paläoanthropologen ja und zwar für carl
von linné beschreibungen 1
die nun nicht mehr nur auf die hautfarbe
zielen ja also hier hat er verschiedene
eier hier ist amerikaner also ja das auf
verschiedene menschen die also die
unklar waren wo sie hingehören aber auf
jeden fall ich will auf die hauptgruppen
raus amerikaners ja so und jetzt steht
aber hier jetzt steht wenn sie das lesen
ja das ist hier übersetzt ja steht hier
also amerikaners entsteht nicht mehr nur
eine farbe dran sondern jetzt sind es
sozusagen bezeichnungen wie amerikaners
erröten cholerisch aufrecht
außerdem haare schwarz glatt dick nasen
ausgebreitet und so weiter gesicht
sommersprossige mit lang in fast bartlos
beharrlich weiter frei sehen sie diese
zuschreibung sozusagen des verhaltens
jetzt auf diese unterschiedlichen art
beschmiert mit labyrinthischen linien
von gebräuchen gewohnheiten regiert ja
so das ist das erste mal dass also nun
solche rassistischen zuordnungen in die
taxonomie einfließen ja die sind
natürlich heute längst wieder weg ja in
der in der bio
ein taxi aber da sind sie von daher
kommt das 17 58 wenn sie mal gucken was
linie über die europäer und über die
asiaten schreibt also bei den europäern
steht von erbleichen zwei sangui nicht
muskulös haare blond loks augen
himmelblau und so weiter leicht
beweglich scharfsinnig tja erfinderisch
hülle bedeckt mit an gewerk leitung von
gesetz regiert ja so als articus von
dunkel zu platzgeld melancholisch steif
außerdem arisch herzlich und so weiter
grausamen pracht lebend absichtlich
hülle weiter leichte gewinne von
ansichten regiert ja so merken sie was
wenn jetzt zu den zu den afrikanischen
zur beschreibung der von afrikanischen
homo sapiens schwarz phlegmatisch schlaf
haare kohlschwarz verworrenen how 2 hd
glatt und so weiter verlängerte brüste
träge gleichgültig mit fett gesalbt und
von der willkür regiert soll das hat
sozusagen seit 1758 ja steht das fest ja
wird auch entsprechend natürlich hat
natürlich auch die die meinung
entsprechend beeinflusst es gab ja nun
sehr viele philosophen vor allem in
europa die alle über das thema rasse
gearbeitet haben und alle einigermaßen
rassistische äußerungen gemacht haben
also aus heutiger sicht ja vielleicht am
progressivsten waren auch georg forster
der also dass immer abgelehnt hat auf
jeden fall wenn man zum beispiel diesen
schule atlas von 1700 von 1842 sieht
dann weiß man warum es geht es geht
nämlich darum und das waren ja auch
alles europäer und das waren ja auch
alles männer ja und deswegen steht ihr
europa ist der kleinste aber der
gebildete erdteil die europäer
übertreffen alle übrigen fälle völker
der erde an künsten und wissenschaften
sowie ihren macht 1842 sollen das ist
das weltbild ja in dem wir uns befinden
ja wo es nun darum geht zu zu erklären
wo der mensch entstanden ist und viel
der mensch entstanden ist ja das heißt
es ist völlig klar ist wo entstanden in
euro
naja und die funde wieder kamen die
ersten die waren ja auch aus europa 1857
aus dem neandertal ja in deutschland ja
es gibt verschiedene rekonstruktionen
übrigens ja hier diesel da hat man dann
schließlich im letzten jahrhundert ist
man dann davon ausgegangen dass die
anderen wernthaler gar nicht so sehr
unterschiedlich sind von von homo
sapiens allerdings die wiege der
menschheit in deutschland ist dann was
ja in europa league ist dann sehr weit
abgewandert sehr schnell nämlich schon
1891 nach asien ja da kamen die ersten
funde von der insel java
ja es kam dann noch viele weitere funde
in den 30er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts so und in dieser situation
ja muss die wiege der menschheit
natürlich wieder nach europa zurück ja
sehr klar der mensch muss in europa
entstanden sein
also hier in diesem kleinen dorf in
england ja haben sich diese herren
überlegt wie machen wir das ja und sie
haben eine fälschung produziert ja das
heißt also hier einige schädelknochen
von menschen ja von homo sapiens
unterkiefer von menschenaffen die zähne
wurden so ein bisschen ab gewalt
gegenseitig das ganze in eine kiesgrube
gepackt und dort wurde ist dann gefunden
ja so und das ist die das ist diese
fälschung das ist die rekonstruktion der
fälschung interessant daran ist dass die
fälschen genauso gemacht wurde wie das
weltbild damals war nämlich beginn der
menschwerdung ein großes gehirn ja und
der rest war sozusagen dann affen mäßig
und vierbeiner das sollte also ein
vierbeiner gewesen sein der begonnen hat
ein großes gehirn zu entwickeln wo in
england natürlich also das kommt dazu
die wiege der menschheit musste
zurückgeholt werden nicht also natürlich
nicht nach frankreich oder nach
deutschland sondern nach england in dem
fall ja und deswegen war es ein
riesengroßer schock als dann 1925 ein
fossil zu tage kam von einer völlig
unerwarteten stelle auf der welt nämlich
aus dem südlichen afrika
dieses fossil hier das also ein gesetz
schädel unterkiefer und dann der
innenausbau von einem gehirn von einer
gehirn schale der erfinder mandat war
neuroanatomie und er hat sofort gesagt
dieses wesen ist immer also dauernd
aufrecht gegangen so woher hat er das
gewusst vom ansatz des rückenmarks also
wenn das rückenmark dahinten ansetzt ja
dann ist das ein vierbeiner
da ist es aber nicht deswegen macht das
gleich wieder weg sondern der ansatz des
rückenmarks ist hier unter dem unter dem
gehirn ja und das ist ein zweibeiner
andauernde einer der den dauernden
aufrechten gang hat ja und wenn sie
nochmal die fälschung vergleichen dann
ist das ja exakt das gegenteil also hier
ist das ein großes gehirn kombiniert mit
dem vierbeinigen gang ja und hier ist es
ein kleines gerät kombiniert mit dem
aufrechten gang mit dem zweibeinigen
gang
das heißt also dieses weltbild hat sich
hier komplett umgedreht
das dumme war nur dass dieses fossil aus
afrika kam das hat das hat mindestens 20
jahre gedauert bis überhaupt irgendeiner
mal so angefangen hat das ernst zu
nehmen nämlich erst durch weitere funde
in den 30er jahren aber das
wissenschaftliche weltbild war so nah
und die fälschung hat das bewiesen
übrigens dass das eine fälschung war
konnte man erst in den 50er jahren des
letzten jahrhunderts beweisen durch die
c14 methode die extra zudem als in der
tier und oded extra zu dem zweck
eigentlich entwickelt wurde und das ding
endlich mal als fälschung zu entlarven
also wie gesagt dass dieses diese
ansicht dass nun der beginn der
menschwerdung nicht das große gehirn war
sondern der aufrechte gang ja das ist
etwas das gibt es seit 1925 es gibt
inzwischen hunderte von fossilien aus
afrika und kein einziges zeit irgendwas
anderes das heißt also das ist zumindest
eine wahrscheinlichkeit eine sehr hohe
das oder es ist nahezu gewissheit da
würde ich sagen dass nun der beginn der
mensch werde nicht das große gähnen war
sondern ist eben gesagt habe der
aufrechte gang
ramon tat ja der der der dieses dieses
erste fossil beschrieben hat von
australopithecus hat dass
australopithecus genannt also das ist
auch ein schriebl sword das ist
lateinisch und griechisch kombiniert
also südafrika hat das ganze mensch sie
ist das ganze mensch zu nennen
also wir stammen ja nicht von den
menschenaffen ab sein den die heutigen
menschenaffen und wir haben einen
gemeinsamen vorfahren ja so muss man das
ausdrücken hat schon gesagt dass das
irgendwo auf dieser linie dann
angesiedelt ist arbeit des
australopithecus genannt zur und raymond
hat dann gleichzeitig eine hypothese
entwickelt zur kultur dieser vor
menschen ja die sogenannte
osteopathische kultur also auch ein
schwieriges wort das ist also aus theo
heyes knochen donto zähne katie korn
osteopathische kultur also die sollen
knochen und hörner und zähne benutzt
haben um also zu jagen und so weiter und
vor allem hat er und das war also in die
die demokratische kultur wo der
besonders bedeutend in den 60er jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts nämlich zur
zeit des kalten kriegs ja das war
nämlich die aggressions hypothese zum
ursprung von homo sapiens davon zum
ursprung der hominiden also da wurde
gesagt die menschen mussten aggressiv
sein um zu zehn zudem zu werden was sie
heute sind ja und da wurde also
beschrieben wie die also mit diesen mit
diesen werkzeugen dann sich gegenseitig
auch übrigens die schädel eingeschlagen
haben es gibt nämlich funde
wo also löcher im schädel sind ja und da
wurde von rem und beschrieben wie die
sich also gegenseitig damit den hörnern
umgebracht haben also alles ganz
blutrünstig aber das hat in die zeit
gepasst ich habe ja vorher gesagt
weltbilder also zur zeit des kalten
kriegs war diese aggression hypothese
durchaus eine sehr wichtige killer app
nennt er ja interessanterweise in den
70er jahren 80er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts
war es dann hauptsächlich die rolle der
frau in der evolution die untersucht
wurde und heute wird hauptsächlich die
rolle des klimas in der evolution
untersucht dass menschen das heißt sie
sehen auch das was wir forschen ist
nicht unabhängig von den weltbildern um
uns herum
übrigens das wurde dann doch noch
entlarvt also diese löcher hier in dem
schädel die kommen nämlich von leoparden
und nicht von hörnern die also von
irgendwelchen artgenossen herein
gestochen wurden sondern von leoparden
die die beute auf die bäume geschleppt
haben ja und und dadurch sind die dann
da in die höhlen gefallen die da unten
drunter sind so also aggressions
hypothese ja im gesicht in den 60er
jahren
wir sehen das heute völlig anders gucken
sie diesen fund an der iss 4,4 millionen
jahre alt das ist ein fund der ist
kürzlich publiziert worden also ein
skelett aus äthiopien also relativ lange
beine kurze beine und lange arme also
der beginn des aufrechten gangs übrigens
ist nicht sind nicht die langen beine
die wir heute haben die langen arme die
beine haben sich dann erst im laufe der
zeit verlängert um diesen aufrechten
gang dann also um energie zu sparen bei
dem aufrechten gang ja also was ganz
wichtig ist bei diesem fund oder was vor
allem noch wichtig ist außerdem
aufrechten gang ja das sind die eckzähne
also hier sehen sie die eckzähne von
schimpansen hier die eckzähne von homo
sapiens und wir haben ja alle sehr
verkleinerter eckzähnen ja die frage ist
warum ja so was haben die akzente für
eine funktion also bei den schimpansen
es ist gut die werden auch bei den
männlichen schimpansen meine ich jetzt
bei den männlichen schimpansen werden
also aus tötungs instrumente eingesetzt
aber eben auch zur bedrohung so und wer
wird bedroht natürlich nicht wilde tiere
oder so sachen also die männchen
bedrohungen sich gegenseitig zur
monopolisierung von weibchen und jetzt
ist es natürlich so wenn wenn man sich
fragt was mit den aktien passiert ist ja
bei homo sapiens sind die eckzähne weg
oder verkleinert der geschrien keine
rolle
und wenn wir jetzt hier gucken bei dem
fund von 4,4 millionen jahren
das sind sie bereits stark verkleinert
das heißt die verkleinerung der eckzähne
steht auch ganz am anfang dieser
menschheitsentwicklung eben nicht nur
der aufrechte gang sondern auch die
verkleinerung der eckzähne was ganz
wichtig ist was bedeutet das das
bedeutet wenn die eckzähne nicht mehr
also eckzähne herzustellen im lauf
sozusagen der unter genese kostet ja
energie
das heißt wenn das kein
selektionsvorteil ist ja der werden sie
sofort nicht mehr nicht mehr gebildet ja
völlig klar dass wie bei unseren
waldszenen die braucht auch keiner mehr
ja die nahrung die wir essen braucht
keiner weise sind das heißt die meisten
haben die ja schon nicht mehr oder die
fallen früher aus oder werden
rausgezogen also das heißt mit anderen
worten die frage ist wenn diese eckzähne
nicht mehr gebraucht werden ja dann
müsste sich auch in dem im
sozialverhalten dieser dieser vor
menschen etwas drastisches verändert
haben und genau das ist das vor wovon
wir heute ausgehen dass es eben nicht
aggressivität ist ja die die
entscheidende rolle spielt in der
frühphase der evolution des menschen
sondern kooperation ja und dieses
kooperative verhalten
das ist etwas was sozusagen die menschen
auch den menschenaffen voraus hat sie
kennen vielleicht die experimente
also wenn das macht man ja mit kindern
und mit schimpansen und das ist also
technisch alles kein problem für niemand
von denen also das ist so
das ist so ein glaskasten ja das sind
zwei eröffnungen drin und dahinter ist
ein tisch und da sind zwei bananen
darauf ja wenn sie das mit kindern
machen also die merken schnell dann
wissen beide zusammen rein fassen also
wenn nur einer rein fast verkannte der
tisch und das kommt nicht her ja das
heißt da muss keiner rein fassen tisch
gemeinsam anziehen und dann können sie
die bananen rausholen und dann holen sie
dir aus und verteilen die bitteschön
die eckzähne primär würde ich für die
bedrohungen des wendigen oder es ist
auch hat es auch mit fleisch
ja ja ich habe ihnen gesagt die werden
ab und ja aber ich erzähle ja gerade
dass kooperation durchaus etwas ist was
so zusammen bitte nein moment also ich
habe ja gesagt auch als bildungs
instrument aber das kommt ganz selten
vor also die haupt bedeutung dieser
aktion ist ein sozusagen ein
bedrohungspotenzial wir konnten sogar
nachweisen dass das dass diese eckzähne
abgelöst werden durch breite wangen es
gibt tatsächlich merkmale er die sich
entwickeln
das heißt also attraktivität statt
aggression das kommt auch noch dazu den
punkt wollte ich jetzt gar nicht erwähnt
aber das ist sozusagen ein prozess mit
mehreren faktoren die sich verändern
aber was ich sagen wollte ist diese
kooperation die ist die ist durchaus
nachzuweisen in diesen experimenten also
wenn jetzt zwei kinder diesen tisch
anziehen
ja dann zieht die dinge gemeinsam ran
holen die zwei bananen raus und kriegt
jeder eine so wenig anpassen das machen
ja das funktioniert exakt so also die
probieren darum und der kraft einer rein
und verkantete tisch dann kommt der
zweite müsse das zusammen raus sind so
und jetzt kommt aber entscheiden und er
sieht dann zieht nämlich einer die
beiden bananen raus und ist sie beide
auf ja das heißt also es gibt viele
experimente in dieser richtung das heißt
diese kooperationsfähigkeit ja die kann
ich natürlich jetzt nicht hier aus
diesen eckzahlen so direkt ablesen das
geht nur indem sozusagen in unserem
weiteren weltbild heute zum verhalten
von menschen aufgrund von menschen
glaube ich schon dass das eine sehr hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit hat das wird übrigens
später noch wichtig bei werkzeugen ja
denn sie wissen ja dass schimpansen
inzwischen wissen der menschenaffen
benutzen nicht nur werkzeuge sein als
sie stellen sie auch her
früher hätte man gesagt das können nur
menschen das ist schon längst also
inzwischen weiß man dass können
schimpansen auch der entscheidende
unterschied ist aber
dass sie sozusagen das wissen über diese
steinwerkzeuge nicht über eine engere
population hinaus weiter geben und das
ist genau wie diese
kooperationsfähigkeit das ist bei bei
frühen menschen vor zweieinhalb
millionen jahren kommen nachher noch
drauf die dann anfangen werkzeuge zu
benutzen der haupt erfolg liegt darin in
dieser kooperation über die gesamte
population und das machen schimpansen
nicht ja das ist klar also ich denke
schon dass das eine sehr hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit hat dass diese
eckzähne deswegen reduziert wurden
weil sie eben für für für diese
inhaltlichen bedrohung nicht gebraucht
wurden das dass sie reduziert worden
wären weil nun werkzeuge dagewesen wären
das ist überhaupt nicht der fall denn
die werden schon vor fünf millionen
jahren reduziert die ersten werkzeuge
gibt es vor zwei millionen vor
zweieinhalb millionen gang
na ja das kommt alles viel später also
das ist der entscheidende punkt dass
kommt 2 das kommt ungefähr 2,5 millionen
jahre später also fleisch und so weiter
zunahmen der fleisch- und kommen wir
nachher drauf das sind zwei millionen
jahre und zwei millionen jahre sind
wieviel 400.000 generationen also das
ist sehr viel später
das hat damit überhaupt kann damit
nichts zu tun um gut
also ich komme jetzt genau zu dem
zeitpunkt denn die ich eben angesprochen
habe nämlich zwei millionen jahre später
passiert dann etwas ja etwas mysteriöses
und das ist sozusagen genau in diesem
zeitraum zwischen 2,6 und 2,4 millionen
jahren
das sind das sind 200.000 jahre das sind
10.000 generationen ja innerhalb von
10.000 generation was relativ schnell
ist in der evolution ja gibt es eine
aufspaltung dieser vor menschen die wir
jetzt eben kennen
und haben ja die also zwei einig sind
und eckzähne reduziert haben aber noch
ein kleines gehirn haben eine
aufspaltung in zwei verschiedene gruppen
nämlich einerseits in die sogenannten
nussknacker menschen warum die so heißen
sage ich gleich ein andererseits in die
gattung mensch also diese das können
auch nur 5000 generationen gewesen sein
das war ein ganz rasanter prozess die
frage ist warum also das gehirn war hier
überall noch überhaupt nicht vergrößert
es gab noch keine keine überwiegende
fleisch namen und sei das kommt alles
erst danach ja und zwar ist es so dass
in afrika zu dieser zeit gibt es gibt es
regenzeiten und trockenzeiten also es
gibt so wie in europa jahres zeigen aber
nicht wie hier im gebiet kalt und warm
sondern trocken und feucht ja so und in
den fäusten jahreszeiten er gibt es ein
völlig anderes nahrungsangebot als in
den trockenen jahreszeiten als in den
regen zeigen gibt es insekten blätter
blüten früchte kleine säugetiere die man
finden kann in den trockenzeiten
reduziert sich das alles auf hartfaser
heilige nahrung ja so und es gab nun
genau in diesen 5000 generationen sind
die regenzeiten in afrika fast völlig
ausgefallen
und deswegen gab es letztendlich ein
nahrungsangebot was sehr stark reduziert
war auf diese art phase gehabt einige
nahrung und da gab es jetzt hoffentlich
offensichtlich zwei lösungen für diese
herausforderung nämlich einerseits eine
biologische lösung hat farbige nahrung
zu zerkleinern das war diese biologische
konstruktion nussknacker mensch ja also
was es damit auf sich das sind das sind
schädel die haben ein sehr breites
gesicht ja riesige loch bögen hier große
zähne dreimal so groß wie bei uns halten
und dann haben sie diesen knochen kommen
da oben ja drauf also dieser knochen
kann das ist der kommt daher dass ist
die kaumuskulatur die sitzt an der seite
her
können sie auch spüren weil sie sich
wenn du es dir hier irgendwo aufhören um
bei denen ist es so dass entwickelt die
sich innerhalb von 5.000 generationen
von beiden seiten auf den schädel und
stößt in der mitte hier oben zusammen so
dass sie ein riesiges muskelpaket
entsteht wie bei den raub
das darf man nicht mehr sagen zur raute
hier dürfen sie nicht sagen das ist
beutegreifer heißen die jetzt nur die
rauben ja nichts mehr
vielleicht auch aus ethischer sicht
interessant also die beutegreifer
jedenfalls die haben ein riesiges
muskelpaket kennen sie ja bei hunden
oder so dabei und genau so haben wir
hier so ein muskelpaket und damit wird
die hat fast alle die nahrung klein
gekauft das ist die biologische
sozusagen die biologische lösung also
aufgrund von zufälligen veränderungen
und selektionsvorteil von denen die herr
dient mehr muskeln haben hat sich das
entwickelt ja genau in diesem zeitraum
genau in diesen fünf bis zehntausend
generationen so jetzt das wäre
eigentlich alles ganz okay oder die
biologische lösung die gibt es meistens
wenn sonst nichts passiert aber es gibt
eben gleichzeitig und das passiert exakt
gleichzeitig also wenn ihnen 5000
generationen nicht eng genug gefasst ist
dann muss ich sie enttäuschen enger
kriegen weil also besser kriegen wir das
nicht mehr hin
das ist schon sehr genau rekonstruiert
und da kommt auch auf ein paar hundert
generationen nicht an aber in dieser
zeit passiert eben gleichzeitig noch
etwas anderes sind es gibt auch noch
eine andere lösung für diese
herausforderung ja und das ist nämlich
die die kulturelle lösung ja das heißt
die ersten stein werkzeuge
na ja die sind genau aus diesen zeitraum
2,4 bis 2,6 millionen jahren aus afrika
so und also hier wird ja informationen
transportiert also biologische
information ob's was jetzt passiert okay
ich habe zurückgedrückt zumindest halt
noch mal angucken
also biologische informationen wird
transportiert ja und zwar wie von
generationen zu generationen über die
gene so und das wird von generationen
die generationen weitergegeben so dass
dann diese diese konstruktion entsteht
ja so die kulturelle evolution ja da
wird die information völlig anders
weitergegeben ja nämlich nicht über die
gene ist und er letztendlich dann über
die sprache ja natürlich über nachahmung
und über die sprache so dass wir obwohl
wir keine fossile sprache haben davon
ausgehen können dass das sozusagen je
komplexer die ist die werkzeuge werden
desto komplexer wird auch die sprache im
lauf der zeit also das sind sozusagen
betriebssysteme die aber erst mal eine
million jahre praktisch unverändert
bleiben ja und dann diese zunehmende
sozusagen die zunehmende der transport
von informationen über die sprache hat
natürlich dann riesen vorteile das heißt
also gegenüber der biologischen
information der biologische information
wird von generation zu generation
transportiert und und hier sprach auch
von individuum zu individuum zurück in
den generationen usw
also ich weiss letzte woche hat hier
über natur und kultur geredet also das
ist jedenfalls ein punkt wo das
auseinander hervorgeht ja sozusagen
diese steinwerkzeuge sind eigentlich so
zum ersten mal unter dem einfluss dieser
klimaveränderung und der nahrungs
veränderungen gibt es da eine
notwendigkeit ja sozusagen diese werk
zur kultur zu etablieren ja und ich habe
jetzt vorher schon gesagt dass
schimpansen auch werkzeuge benutzen auch
sogar herstellen aber das bleibt lokal
auf einzelne populationen beschränkt
also da gibt es welche in liberia da
machen die anti sind 20 km von dann
entfernt nicht dass die sich nicht
treffen könnten
aber die machen einfach unterschiedliche
sachen gibts kein austausch keine
kooperation und das ist sozusagen das
wesentliche merkmal in der entwicklung
der gatte moment so und erst danach ja
beginnt es dann das dann fleisch nahrung
verstärkt in die nahrung aufgenommen
also das ist zweieinhalb millionen jahre
nach nach denen über die wir vorher
diskutiert haben die sozusagen aktien
reduziert haben
und und auch feuer nutzung passiert dann
und relativ schnell verlassen dann diese
frühen menschen auch den afrikanischen
kontinent also wenn wir jetzt noch mal
gucken was passiert jetzt vor
dreieinhalb millionen jahren hier aus
dem umfeld des tropischen regenwaldes
wurde wo die alle entstanden sind wo der
aufrechte gang entstanden ist im umfeld
des tropischen regenwaldes wurde er sehr
stark zurück gegangen ist wo sich zur
warnen ausgebreitet haben gibt es eine
ausbreitung dann ins östliche ins
östlichen westliche und ins südliche
afrika vor drei millionen jahren dann
für zweieinhalb millionen jahren
entsteht die erste nur menschen im
tropischen bereich und die nussknacker
menschen es gibt noch ein paar andere
wanderungsbewegung oder
migrationsbewegungen und dann vor zwei
millionen jahren kommt es zu den ersten
auswanderungen aus afrika richtung
südostasien über die über die das noch
mal machen
also es kommt dann vor zwei millionen
jahren zu den ersten aussagen also wenn
ich aus wanderungen sage meine ich
natürlich nicht dass die jetzt gesagt
haben okay wir gehen jetzt mal da nach
südostasien und machen sich auf
wanderschaft sondern das ist ja deswegen
ist das wort eigentlich das falsche man
müsste expansion sagen das sind ja ganz
langsam expansionen im sommer fünf
kilometer pro generation ja wenn sie
jetzt 10.000 kilometer da bis nach
südostasien
dann brauchen sie 2000 generationen und
2000 generation x 20 jahre berechnet da
20 jahre pro generation heute brauchen
wir es ab ins rechnen mit 30 jahre aber
damals 20 dann brauchen sie 40.000 jahre
und das ist ja geologisch gesehen nichts
ja das ist ja eben sozusagen im in den
funkwagen kaum zu entdecken diese 40.000
jahre unterschied
und selbst hier die ausbreitung
nach südeuropa also geht ja ist ja gar
kein problem wenn man das andere ufer
sieht natürlich kommt die nicht an da in
gibraltar und auf der anderen seite und
sagen dann wir wollen jetzt mehr oder da
und wollen darüber sondern die sitzen
vielleicht da fünf generationen oder 10
oder meinetwegen auch 100 das spielt
jetzt da keine große rolle
bis dann da mal rüber geht also hier
nach südspanien hier in die levante bis
nach georgien bisschen kaukasus und hier
dann aus breitungen bis nach südostasien
und dann erst vor ungefähr 800.000
jahren wird mitteleuropa besiedelt und
zwar gibt es hier einen berühmten funkt
der ist gefunden worden der heißt homo
heidelbergensis der berühmte unterkiefer
und es gibt ein buch da steht drin der
sei in einer mauer war heidelberg
gefunden worden
stimmt aber nicht sondern ist in der
ortschaft mauer bei heidelberg gefunden
worden
ja und zwar 1907 es gibt hinweise darauf
dass dieser fund
erinnern sie sich noch mal die fälschung
weil die man 1913 von dates vorgelegt
hat ja und die und die usa sind das 1891
das heißt es gibt durchaus hinweise
darauf dass dieser fund in der nähe von
heidelberg dann die engländer noch mehr
angestachelt hat ja diese fälschung zu
machen denn da wurde gesagt das ist
jetzt tatsächlich als der ursprung der
menschheit in europa wieder ein bereits
jetzt zeige ich ihnen aber mal ganz kurz
was da nur eine kleine auswahl was hat
er alles gefunden wurde also einander
thaler 1909 dann köpfe das in afrika 19
21 steinheimer 1933 also alle die jetzt
hier auftauchen wurden dann letztendlich
als sozusagen als ursprung des menschen
interpretiert ja hier aus südostasien
aus krisenland unserer 60 aus der
schlucht
tansania dann sang gewann in auf der
insel java arango in frankreich sind
unsere 71 dann die funde von oz
trockener das sind die funde von richard
leakey am ostufer des pkws äthiopien
1976 und dann westtor keiner der turkana
bei 84 also atapuerca in spanien und da
gibt es noch verschiedene andere funde
die manege dass die fundstelle in
georgien ja herr tor in äthiopien und
dann schließlich die kleinen flores
menschen 2004 von insel flores also
immer wird gesagt oder die manie sie
doch mal 2000 über immer wird gesagt so
kann jedes mal weg gebracht wo ist denn
jetzt die wiege der menschheit und also
ganz einfach wir brauchen das nur zu
sortieren ja also nach fund jahr zu
satiren bringt nicht viel
das ist wie wenn man die bibliotheken
nach farben sortieren würde ja also es
gibt zwei schöne zwei besseres sortier
kriterien nämlich einerseits und das ist
ganz einfach für fossilien nach dem
geologischen alter ja so das biologische
alter wenn wir das jetzt mal machen und
das sortieren was sehen wir da also da
sind zwei millionen 1,5 1.500.000 250
50.000 wir sehen unser heidelberger ja
ist irgendwo im mittelfeld ja es gibt
welche die viel viel älter sind so jetzt
muss man aber nochmals rotieren dann so
hat man auch noch nicht wirklich den
überblick und das zweite ist ihr
kriterium in der paläoanthropologie oder
in der paläontologie ist was die
geografische lage natürlich ja denn es
ist ja schon unterschied wo die funde
herkommen und wenn man jetzt das jetzt
bleibt das albert gleich und wir
sortieren noch mal einfach nach
geographischer lage so dann haben wir
hier europa ja die funde aus europa hier
aus afrika und hier aus asien und was
sehen wir
wir sehen dass es eine lückenlose
entwicklung gibt und da brauchen sie es
gar keine anatomischen kenntnisse
anzuwenden
also es gibt eine lückenlose entwicklung
in afrika vom ursprung der gattung homo
vor zweieinhalb millionen jahren bis zum
homo sapiens ja da spielt europa keine
rolle der spieler sind auch keine runde
ganz einfach natürlich gibt es also zum
auswanderungen aus afrika nach euro
und auch nach asien was in europa
entsteht also irgendwie habe ich heute
ein problem
also sie wollen das jetzt nicht alles
noch mal angucken bitte nein das wollen
sie nicht das dauert zu lang
ich muss das jetzt leider ich muss
leider hier auf gehen ja sonst so jetzt
lassen wir das noch mal sortieren
ok also wir haben jetzt hier asien
afrika und europa von rechts nach links
und was man sieht ist das sozusagen die
funde hier durchgehend in afrika hin zum
homo sapiens führen ja ok und was was
das natürlich jetzt bedeutet ist das
sozusagen irgendwo ja hier in europa
entsteht ja was ja es entstehen die
einander thaler das sind aber nicht
unsere vorfahren ja unsere vorfahren
kommen aus afrika und auch hier diese
funde sind nicht unsere vorfahren ja
also in der chinesischen stadt
paläoanthropologie ist das ein bisschen
anders da gibt es in der tat also
sozusagen die pflicht für jeden
paläoanthropologen nachzuweisen dass die
menschheit in china entstanden ist aber
das ist nicht mit dem zu vereinbaren
also wenn sie die kollegen privat
sprechen sagen ja auch das ist natürlich
nicht so aber sozusagen auch hier ein
weltbild was hier so aufrecht erhalten
wird also diese verteilung sozusagen ja
die neandertaler die sind dann in europa
ausgestattet ausgestorben nachdem sich
homo sapiens über die ganze welt
ausgebreitet hat ja und was haben wir
heute für eine situation ja heute haben
wir eine situation mit verschiedenen
geographischen varianten die wir
erklären müssen
und sie wissen das wurde so als rassen
wurde das erklärt ja und sie wissen
natürlich auch in den weltbild in dem
europäischen wie das erklärt wurde
ja also wir haben hier in der nummer als
beispiel höhe des menschen in den zonen
und rassen ja das ist klar wenn sie hier
gucken
das ist auch von 1848 glaube ich ja so
einzelne deutsche hirne sind natürlich
die größten jahr und die buschmänner
sind die kleinsten das heißt es ist klar
die erklärung dafür wo die menschheit ja
wo die menschheit gestanden ist das kann
immer noch nur europa seien ja und es
gab einen berühmten hier einen berühmten
oder berühmt berüchtigten veranstalter
ja antonio farina der hat also sehr
viele so einer veranstaltung gemacht er
hat nämlich genau die buschleute die
columbus leute aus afrika geholt und hat
sie präsentiert in europa soße als
primitive menschen ja und hier sind sie
und so wurde also dann im 18 im
neunzehnten aber sogar noch fast bis ins
zwanzigste bis ins 20 jahrhundert hinein
wurde so natürlich immer wieder gesagt
ja die die primitiven menschen sind
überall nur nicht in europa und sie sind
hauptsächlich in afrika und außerdem
wurde natürlich gesagt afrika hat keine
geschichte ja sie wissen ja kennen den
spruch kommt dass afrika keine
geschichte hat kommt natürlich daher
wahlgeschichte definiert wurden ja nach
seither dort als alles was
aufgeschrieben ist ja aber wir wissen
eben heute oder wir gehen heute davon
aus dass geschichte natürlich viele
andere faktoren hat also geschichte sind
eben für uns heute auch reste aus der
paläoanthropologie die sich nicht selbst
interpretieren
also diese diese methode hier also
afrikaner auszustellen und zu sagen dass
das also sozusagen die die primitiven
menschen sind sie kennen das ja das hat
ja in den zoos war das ja also gang und
gäbe in paris aber übrigens auch in
deutschland in hamburg und so weiter bei
hagenbeck und so also auf jeden fall
hier sehen sie da schon die afrikaner
werden hier katja 1953 sei dank roger
das ist das heutige simbabwe
dieser wettkampf queen madonna ist man
da waren diese
dörfer aufgebaut übrigens noch hier 2005
zoologischer garten in augsburg gab es
also wissen ja vielleicht gab es ein
riesen riesen protest das nicht genau
hier genau das gemacht wurde african
village nur nebenher aber das geht zieht
sich alles bis heute durch und wenn wir
noch mal kommen zurück auf diese auf den
beginn der der menschwerdung dieser homo
rudolfensis dieser älteste angehörige
der gattung mensch der 1993 beschrieben
wurde unter anderem mit funden aus
malawi da gab es zwei verschiedene
rekonstruktionen also das war ja
sozusagen der älteste anlage der
kategorie ich zeige ihnen jetzt hier 22
weltbilder also zwei rekonstruktionen
dass einer aus der zeitschrift focus ja
hier
der guckt so ein bisschen drüber und
jetzt zeige ich ihnen den aus der
zeitschrift spiegel der ist praktisch
gleichzeitig erschienen ja hier und das
ist der intellektuelle typus und ganz
klar hat helle hautfarbe ja im spiegel
das wurde alles noch ein bisschen eine
dunkel später aber das hat es auch nicht
besser gemacht also die helle hautfarbe
ist natürlich etwas das kommt sehr spät
das kommt erst mit dem song mit mit
auswanderung in die nördlichen
breitengraden dieser hautfarbe nämlich
auch so hier ach ja das können sie alles
nett biologie 1996 ja wunderbare rassen
einteilung ja immer noch bis zum
heutigen tag hier fasching schminke
berlin 1978 also ich will ihnen nur
klarmachen dass das natürlich in unserer
aller köpfe drin ist ja und und dass das
auch kein wunder ist denn das ist seit
fünf sechs sieben acht neun generationen
unseren köpfen drin ja und da hat die
paläoanthropologie in verbindung mit der
modernen genetik und die aufgabe
letztendlich dieses weltbild zu ändern
und das ist auch ganz einfach denn
hautfarbe zb hängt nicht nur
ausschließlich ab von uv-strahlung ja
wenn sie hier angucken
die uv-strahlung ja und wenn sie jetzt
die verteilung der
hautfarben angucken dann stimmt die
genau überein
das muss so sein denn die uv strahlung
ja ist zum teil schädlich wird aber zum
teil auch gebraucht ja und zwar für
vitamin d bildung ja und es ist ganz
klar dass wenn jetzt nun die nördlichen
breitengrade besiedelt werden dass diese
pigmentierung zurückgefahren wird
um eben mehr uv strahlung durch die haut
zu lassen zu vitamin d bilden soll da
gibt es einen ganz klaren zusammenhang
ja und natürlich und das hat nun eben
auch im gegensatz zu dem was damals da
geschrieben hat mit irgendwelchen
verhaltensweisen dieser menschen
überhaupt nichts zu tun es gibt
überhaupt keinen anlass anzunehmen ja
wir leben nur noch sagen kurz genetik ja
also bereits 1991 ist dieses in science
dieses diese veröffentlichungen
erschienen zur genomik views of human
history und da ist ganz klar wenn man
alle genetischen faktoren zusammen nimmt
ja alle zusammen dann sind die
unterschiede innerhalb einer population
ja sehr viel größer als zwischen
populationen oder auch als zwischen
populationen von verschiedenen
kontinenten
das heißt was war das okay so und hier
steht einer dieser rast der stand schon
1999 den hammers man sie nicht gelesen
das ist eben überhaupt keine rationale
basis dafür gibt ja also für diese für
die annahme dass es irgendwie rassen
gibt die große genetische unterschiede
haben ja ist die unterschiede ja die
sind da ja aber trotzdem haben wir nicht
unterschiedliche gene sondern in allen
von uns auf der welt ist überall
dasselbe drin nur in unterschiedlichen
anteil das ist die aussage ja so und
deswegen sehen wir das heute so
verschieden und doch gleich das sind so
ein paar titel
und der einzige art von rassismus der
noch zugelassen ist ist dieser hier ja
okay gut
ich will aber ich will aber dass noch
mal kurz zusammenfassen also wir haben
jetzt gesehen es gibt diese vor menschen
vor sechs millionen jahren das spaltet
sich auf in die nussknacker menschen die
dann aussterben und in die gattung
mensch ja es gibt verschiedene faktoren
bei dieser mensch werden also
fortbewegung anatomie gehirnstruktur
sozialverhalten kommunikation und
werkzeuge
ja und wenn sie die breite dieser balken
angucken dann soll das das bedeuten was
da passiert ist zu welcher zeit also für
sechs millionen 543 und soweit also
fortbewegen anatomie da ist das meistens
schon für 6 millionen jahren passiert ja
und heute passiert unheimlich wenig im
also letztendlich bei uns gar nichts
mehr wir verändern uns auch nicht mehr
wir werden auch nichts neues mehr
entwickeln denn wir sind viel zu viele
individuen auf der welt ja um neue arten
zu entwickeln braucht man kleine
abgeschlossene population also aber wo
sich viel entwickelt hat im laufe der
sechs letzten sechs millionen jahren ist
beim gehirn sozialverhalten
kommunikation und werkzeuge
wenn sie die faktoren einzeln betrachten
dann gehen die ewig weit zurück im
privaten stammbaum ja und sie werden nie
eine grenze fest machen wo sich das
anfängt auszuwirken in richtung gattung
mensch erst die überlagerung dieser
faktoren vor ganz kurzer zeit fühlt dann
sozusagen zu etwas ganz neuem also die
auswirkungen überlagern sich und das
führt dann letztendlich vor ungefähr
200.000 jahren zu homo sapiens in afrika
so und dieser homo sapiens in afrika vor
dem wird immer gesagt na ja also dieser
homo sapiens in afrika ist vielleicht
biologisch da entstanden ja aber was ist
denn mit der kultur das will ich jetzt
noch sagen also die die letzten reste
sozusagen der vorstellung dass die
menschheit in europa entstanden ist
ist ja sozusagen mit der biologischen
paläoanthropologie passe menschen sind
eindeutig in afrika entstanden aber
jetzt klingen mahlsteine alessa moderne
menschen vom endverarbeitung und wenn
sie die bücher gucken alles ist in
europa von speerspitzen ja mikroliter
begräbnisse ja so muscheln fischen was
haben wir noch verhandeln also schmuck
fischfang mitteilungen knochen werkzeuge
harpunen ja so und bergbau und
schließlich noch malerei so also in
europa haben wir immer noch und ich darf
das sagen weil ich selber aus der gegend
bin also sie wissen wo die ältesten
kunstwerke her kommen der welt der
ältesten kleinen kunstwerke der welt von
der schwäbischen alb also die schwaben
haben ja das auto erfunden und die
nähmaschinen und so weiter und haben
natürlich selbstverständlich auch die
kunst erfunden ja und das ist sozusagen
das letzte woran sich jetzt alle noch
klammern hier ja aber die ältesten
kunstwerke sind doch von den schwaben
also ich muss jetzt enttäuschen denn
wenn sie und das ist sozusagen jetzt das
aus den letzten fünf jahren was
inzwischen aus afrika kommt ja hier
steht erfindung moderner menschen wenn
sie jetzt das sortieren wo das alles
hier kommen kommt alles aus afrika alles
250.000 jahre also das einzige was noch
nicht in afrika gefunden wurde ist nicht
genau das sozusagen auf der schwäbischen
alb diese kleinen kunstwerke aber in
afrika sind höchstens fünf prozent der
gegend bekannt ja insofern kann ich
jetzt schon also ich prophezeie dass das
internet spätestens in den nächsten zehn
jahren gefunden wird und damit sozusagen
auch noch die kulturelle modernität des
menschen nach afrika verlagert wird so
also homo sapiens hat sich ausgebreitet
von afrika nach europa
danach bis nach australien vor 60.000
jahren gut wir waren ja überall schon
andere hier war ja schon humor actors
nun habe ich ja gesagt die waren vorher
schon da ein der andere teil aber in
europa und so die sind dann alle
ausgestorben aber nicht deswegen weil
die modernen menschen sie umgebracht
haben sondern die aneinander teile
hatten weniger nachfahren moderne
menschen hatten sich viel mehr
nachkommen und da brauchen sie noch ein
paar generationen dann ist sozusagen
biologisch von der einen gruppe nichts
männer also um die ausbreitung dann
sozusagen hierüber über ostasien dann
nach amerika das ist ein sehr später
prozess also vor 35.000 jahren kommt die
besiedlung von südamerika nordamerika
war noch als bedeckt und dann
schließlich vor 10.000 jahren die das
15.000 jahren eine besiedlung von
nordamerika also das sind natürlich
riesige aus breitungen und vermischungen
und so weiter also riesigen ausmaßes die
in der in der evolution der menschheit
stattgefunden haben und das ist
sozusagen die ausbreitung von homo
sapiens aus afrika
allerdings hat homo sapiens in europa
dann vergessen dass er sich mal
ausgebreitet hat ja und dann gab es die
phase von out of europe nämlich
plötzlich wurde alles entdeckt in
anführungszeichen ja homo sapiens hat
das natürlich alles schon bekannt war ja
tausend jahre vorher schon dort aber das
hat man in europa alles vergessen und
dann gab es also 340 so im mittelalter
dann die große entdeckung runde out of
europe und was haben wir heute das jetzt
mein abschlussfrage anziehen was ist
heute das hier ist heute also wir haben
jetzt 2013 homo sapiens 2013 schottet
sich ab in den wohlstands regierungen
der welt also da gibt es natürlich
riesige migrationshintergrund das sind
also gebiete hier die roten das ist
südafrika europa gegenüber
hier gegenüber afrika auch usa
australien
mit grenzsicherung mit zäunen mit mauern
mit minen mit militär patrouillen und
mit bewegungsmelder seiner melder und
selber gelesen dass europa jetzt nichts
anderes zu tun hat als ein system zu
finanzieren was das ganze noch dichter
macht ja und also was wir lernen können
aus der rallye anthropologie ist wir
denken wir einen in vielen generationen
ja ich habe ihnen von tausenden von
generationen bricht oder von 10.000 also
diese situation hier ja die kann
vielleicht noch ein oder zwei
generationen gut gehen ja aber auf
keinen fall 10 20 oder 100 generation ja
und sie wissen ja auch wie sich das
alles aus wirkt ja so also haben sie mal
das bild im kopf und denken sie mal mit
diesem bild im kopf in den nächsten
fünfzig generationen und überlegen sie
sich mal was die sozusagen was wir aus
der paläoanthropologie lernen können gut
vielen dank